Wow! I've never seen such a huge bookstore.
There's even a coffee shop inside of it!
Yeah, this is a pretty famous bookstore chain;...
...they have them all over the country.
I can see why it's so popular.
They must have every book ever written here.
Well, probably not quite that many,...
...but you can find just about any book you want.
I'm looking for that new mystery novel called "The Train Stopped for Nobody".
I don't think I've heard about that one.
Did you say that it's a new novel?
Yes. I think it just came out this month.
Well, all of the new books are over there on that wall.
Hey, I got it.
Where do I go to pay for it?
Back to the checkout at the front of the store.